let's jump to this story from deadline
Joe Biden talks about watching an AI
generated deep fake of himself I said
when the hell did I say that so
apparently Biden wants to launch some AI
safety regulations and guidelines and
things like this they say uh President
Biden signed an executive order on AI
billing the us as outfront of other
countries when it comes to establishing
guard rails around the fast emerging
technology but Biden told those gathered
in the East room that other steps
require congressional action that will
be a much more complicated process as
lawmakers have been an EST stalemate for
years when it comes to any meaningful
action on Tech Giants speaking to
reporters after the White House ceremony
Senate Majority Leader Chuck Schumer
said that all this that his effort to
craft a bill this is about the hardest
thing I attempted to undertake
legislatively because it is so
complicated because a it's so
complicated B it affects every aspect of
society sh said that he and the rest of
the bipartisan group of lawmakers will
meet with Biden on Tuesday to talk about
the legislation I think we're in a post-
legislation uh era of this country y I
don't think legislation is going to get
passed unless it's nonsensical and
irrelevant or jammed into an Omnibus and
uh when it comes to major issues like AI
it's just going to happen and no one's
going to do anything about any of it so
you look at where the internet is today
and kids have access to adult content
and nobody cares in fact there are rant
who argue they should it's the parents
fault and I'm like well I guess it's
like saying it's parents fault if a kid
sneaks if a kid goes to an adult
bookstore and the guy lets him in I
think at a certain point there is a
shared responsibility between the people
granting the access and the parents who
were supposed to be watching their kids
with that being said AI stuff is just
going to keep happening there's not
going to be any regulation and it's
going to get wild and then that's it
there you go you'll live in the pot
you'll eat the book China is going to
control it all
yep I feel confident that China whether
or not the us passes some kind of
restrictions because Mark Mark andreon
is uh frequently talking about doing
some kind of limit on he really wants a
full stop on AI research because he
thinks that it can get out of hand real
fast but I think that that doesn't
really matter because it's not going to
be something that the whole world is
going to abide by even if the you know
us companies or companies that had a
large portion of their business done in
the US even if they committed to
stopping that doesn't mean China's going
to stop and and I don't think that China
is as Cutting Edge as the US is but I
think that they would be or they will be
quickly if the US stops develop if us
firms and companies stop developing I
mean right now Google's as much of the
the military-industrial complex as
rathon is like they're the they are
exactly the same type of of you know
involvement with the with the Warfare
State and the surveillance state so
there's no incentive for these companies
to actually stop no matter what the the
the president passes or executive order
he says I I just don't see it happening
yeah and for me part of the danger with
AI is that it's marketed as just
something fun that we try out and play
right now I mean every time you get
access to uh you know Photoshop just
unveiled a tool that uses AI so you can
use AI to generate things but that is
refining the AI the more exposure the
more people that use it the more
essentially free beta testing they have
for it uh the more complicated of a a
tool it becomes to unravel and I just
don't think that and look I openly
identify as a boom in terms of
Technology but I just don't think
there's any way for the people who are
legislating to legislate effectively and
fively enough to be ahead of this we're
already behind it that's why we're
trying to play catchup uh and I
certainly don't know anyone who can
effectively talk about the ramications
of AI in a way that would eventually
make it into an effective law half of
them can't even open an email and they
they're the people that are going to do
our AI some democratic some I think it
was one of the democratic congressmen
from North Carolina he used to do Tik
toks from the capital and he was like
today I met with you know the head of
Technology at the capital to get my
laptop and he dead panned asked me if I
needed him to show needed help learning
how to open the laptop and learning how
to launch an email Feinstein basically
stayed there dead for six months so it's
just it's ridiculous and these are
supposed to be our leaders the executive
order uh is going is basically going to
direct the Department of Commerce to
develop standards for authentication and
water marking impossible yeah they'll
make the standard it'll be exploited by
them that's what they'll do they'll make
a standard and they'll say this label
certifies a video organic and then
they'll just charge companies for that
organic uh uh uh label yeah so you're
going to be a news organization and
you're going to go to this system and
you're going to be like we're going to
upload the video we're going to certify
it and then they're going to stamp it
and then you're going to pay your your
monthly fee or whatever or your license
per per content fee just like if you
were uh getting other government stamps
on your product or if you're an
independent journalist and you take
video on the ground what's to stop
anyone else from saying oh no this
doesn't have the rights certification or
you didn't upload it correctly or we
have questions about this so now we're
going to lock down your content because
we think it potentially could be AI
generated based on literally nothing
other than we don't really like what
you're filming I mean it's it's not that
I don't want there to be regulation I
think AI is I'm fearful of it but it's
just hard to think of a way that would
be effective and not open a whole bunch
of other problems right you're
right anyways I could we I'll just
continue to talk about why I'm scared of
AI okay here we go no I mean this is the
thing I've had other people suggest to
me that when I'm doing research for
articles that I should turn to J chat
GPT and like ask it questions and chat
GPT can be an incredibly effective tool
but I was just sitting with someone in
the office who was using it to double
check a math equation and chat GPT got
it wrong and so you just can't trust
that the AI intelligence is actually
reliable right I mean it eventually will
develop its own agenda I do not trust it
I don't care what Elon says I'm not
convinced that AI will ever be creative
cuz currently AI is is a essentially it
can only know what's on the internet now
it doesn't come up with any ideas of its
own so I don't and I'm I'm not in any
position to make an authoritative
statement about AI uh but I am skeptical
that it could be creative in the way
that human beings are sure but I imagine
you know once once it reads every book
and listens to every song it's going
it's already at that point where it
knows what people like and then can make
pop music granted if you want to make
art music sure weird experimental and
weird sounds it could certainly do that
just increase the instability in the in
the algorithm and then it'll output
something a little bit weirder so I
don't I don't know what creativity is
going to mean in that context when I say
creativity I'm I'm more thinking in cre
not so much creative like art style or
or musically but like creative as in
like innovation
in fields like I don't think the AI is
going to figure out how to do cold
fusion I disagree I think it will you
think you can figure out because I my my
impression is that without the without
the the information already being there
I feel like it it wouldn't be able to
come up with Innovations was that so
it's like sidoku so they've uh the
periodic table for instance per periodic
table of elements when it was first made
there was like huge gaps in it and
they're like there's probably something
there based on this already and then
we're filling it in and we're like whoa
there's like a whole section here and so
what I think it's going to be like a
sodoku puzzle once enough data is
plugged into the AI it's going to spit
out hey guys see these things right here
there's there's a particle there a
particle there there's an element there
we're going to be like wow we could not
see these things and then it's not going
to know it's going to say based on all
of the pieces laid out I'll put it this
way we're loading all the puzzle pieces
of this 50 billion piece jigsaw puzzle
into this machine machine and then it's
sorting them and then showing us the
picture and we're like there's huge gaps
in where there should be things here now
we know what pieces are missing we know
what to look for but it's but it's also
going to be able to uh predict what
those pieces are going to be especially
on like you know things like elements
for instance and and particles and and
permutations of various compounds or
whatever it's going to be able to be
like this you know I remember watching
these old movies where the scientist
like inputs into the computer you know a
formula and then presses enter and then
it's like formula unstable and I'm like
when how's the computer know I'm like oh
back then probably not but today yes oh
yeah you'll be able to input a sequence
and then it'll tell you like here's what
will happen if going to know much more
than we can think it's going to really
advance I think exponentially very fast
and yeah it's going to be a very very
quick transition within 10 years it's
going to be really Advanced I don't
think 10 years you think even faster
than that even faster than that because
when the singular when the singularity
happens it will be instant if it's
faster it's still it's scary cuz they'll
use it against us somehow you know it
always starts good self against us yeah
it's going to be a tool that's going to
end up probably destroying us like
everything else ends up being we said oh
Alexa even Alexa was so good Alexa's
reporting people to the cops but that's
why I I never understood the draw to
Alexa because it's always listening that
seems like like you bug your
own many crimes has Alexa turned in
their owners for it's ridiculous and
they allow yeah I know a few people who
got caught on I don't know them
personally but I see them on you can
subpoena the recordings from Alexa the
first you should do is get those things
the hell out of your house it's
craziness it's craziness I had a boss
who was like we'll put them in every
office and I was like I have to leave
the job I that everyone should
understand that if if you have concerns
about Alexa you should make sure you
shouldn't have a smartphone either no
you need to keep that all move to the
woods and the mountains no I mean this
is the hard thing which is that I
understand some technology is really
valuable and can change the lives of
people Advanced business this that and
the other but ultimately what are we
sacrificing to pay for right all these
things especially again I go back to
sort of the free access to AI or you
know lowcost access to some AI programs
that are essentially uh allowing you to
test AI out and it's testing you out
there is a cost and we're not going to
know it until it's too late and that's
what I'm fearful of yep I have uh Alexa
in my apartment but I don't have Alexa
in my uh at my house in in New Hampshire
why would you have it in your apartment
Phil because it's just the apartment
it's not the house in New Hampshire you
crazy it's not the Fortress of Solitude
you should protect all of the fortresses
even your your satellite office here in
West Virginia the apartment is not is
not a uh a fortress so you can talk to
your dog when you're gone is that what
you're saying no a little bit no no not
at all thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net